Amigos, os hago una pregunta:
¿Os habéis parado alguna vez a pensar cuánto
gasta de verdad, cuánto le cuesta, realmente,
a los Estados Unidos su ejército y todas
las operaciones militares que lleva a cabo
día tras día a lo largo y ancho del mundo?
Pues bien, eso es precisamente, a lo que vamos
a tratar de responder en este vídeo.
Y, ojo, amigos, porque este no es un debate
cualquiera.
La industria militar es una de las industrias
más opacas, más influyentes y más poderosas
de los Estados Unidos.
[Bueno… de los Estados Unidos y prácticamente
de todo el mundo.]
Así que amigos, contestar a la pregunta que
os he realizado, supone ni más ni menos,
que abrir un debate cuyas implicaciones no
son precisamente pequeñas.
La factura puede ser de cientos de miles de
millones de dólares.
Pero bien, hecha esta advertencia, ahora ya
sí, veamos que está ocurriendo en los pasillos
tanto del Pentágono como del Capitolio.
Hablar del ejército en Estados Unidos supone
tener en cuenta cifras desorbitantes, y también,
una inmensa maquinaria burocrática y política.
Tan grande y tan opaca que prácticamente
podemos hablar de un gobierno paralelo.
Fijaos:
(Un informe del propio Pentágono en 2015
cifró en decenas de miles de millones, repito,
decenas de miles de millones de dólares,
cada año, el sobrecoste causado por malas
prácticas en la gestión de las Fuerzas Armadas.)
Malas prácticas como por ejemplo, pagar a
contratistas privados más dinero del que
cabría esperar en un mercado competitivo.
("Vamos a estar en peligro porque estamos
gastando dólares como si no importara".
Robert L. Stein, Director de Chartwell Capital Management y expresidente de
la Junta de Negocios de Defensa.)
Y, ojo, no penséis solo en las grandes empresas
de la industria militar, esas que se encargan de
producir los cazas, los misiles y demás equipos
militares, para nada.
Una buena parte de todos estos miles de millones
que cada año se evaporan proceden de actividades
como la contabilidad, la logística o los
recursos humanos.
¡Tal cual como lo escucháis!
De hecho, la burocracia de las Fuerzas Armadas
de Estados Unidos es tan grande, que emplea
ni menos que a algo más de 1 millón de personas.
¡1 millón de personas para cosas como contabilidad  o recursos humanos!
Atentos a este gráfico del Washington Post:
Cómo veis el ejército de Estados Unidos
tiene prácticamente tantas personas en los
despachos, en actividades administrativas,
como preparándose para la guerra o realizando
tareas de seguridad o entrenamiento.
Y todo esto, claro,  tiene un coste: casi una cuarta
parte del presupuesto militar se invierte
en este tipo de tareas… que bueno...digamos
que son importantes… pero… ¿Una cuarta parte?
En otras palabras, toda esta burocracia, por
sí misma, supondría el tercer mayor presupuesto
militar del mundo y no estaría lejos de la
segunda plaza de China.
(Y eso no es todo.
Según un estudio del mismo Departamento de
Defensa, publicado en Octubre de 2017, aproximadamente
1 de cada 5 instalaciones que tiene el Pentágono,
no vale para nada, está ociosa… podrían
cerrarlas sin ninguna consecuencia militar y
ahorrarse muchos millones de dólares… pero
digamos que los políticos de Washington no
están muy por la labor.)
[[Por cierto, en la descripción os dejo el enlace
a varios de estos informes]]
Cómo veis, amigos, todo lo que tiene que
ver con el Pentágono y
el Departamento de Defensa de Estados Unidos
supone hablar de estructuras hiper burocráticas,
elefantiasis y muy, muy costosas.
Pues bien, como luego veremos en este vídeo,
todo este derroche tiene una gran importancia
en el debate político.
Pero ahora ya sí, veamos cuánto dinero le
suponen realmente a los Estados Unidos sus
aventuras militares.
(EL COSTE DE LAS GUERRAS)
A decir verdad, las aventuras militares de
Estados Unidos no son algo nada extraño.
Si contamos la Guerra Fría, Estados Unidos
ha estado virtualmente en guerra prácticamente
todos los años desde, atentos, 1941.
Y además, lo conocemos todos, desde finales
de 2001, el ejército norteamericano ha estado
activamente en combate todos los años…
y ¿sabéis qué?
No parece que las cosas vayan a cambiar en
un futuro próximo.
Siria, las operaciones en el Índico, en África,
en Yemen, en Europa del Este…y sobre todo,
por supuesto, las guerras de Irak y Afganistán.
¿Os hacéis una idea de cuánto han costado
todos estos conflictos?
Pues atentos porque la cifra es… de escándalo.
Pero antes un apunte, una cosa es el presupuesto
anual de defensa… y otra el presupuesto
de operaciones.
Es decir, cuando escuchamos hablar de cuánto
gasta EEUU en su ejercito no se suele tener
en cuenta el coste propio de las guerras y
operaciones militares.
Pues bien, el caso es que desde 2001 los contribuyentes estadounidenses
se han gastado, tan solo en estas aventuras
militares, la friolera de 1,7 billones de
dólares.
(¡1,7 billones!
Tanto como el tamaño combinado, la suma del
PIB anual, de las economías de Colombia,
Perú, Argentina, Chile, Ecuador, Uruguay,
Panamá, Bolivia, Paraguay y Guatemala
¡Que se dice pronto!)
Visto de otra forma, en dólares de hoy, es más del doble de lo que costó la Guerra de Vietnam
o 5 veces el coste de la Guerra de
Korea.
Pero ojo, porque si pensáis que esta cifra
es elevada… esperad porque aún no hemos
terminado.
El gasto de las guerras de Irak y Afganistán,
por ejemplo, aún no ha terminado… y no
me refiero solo al gasto militar que queda
por delante… sino a los costes que ya se
han producido pero que el gobierno federal tendrá
que pagar en el futuro:
(Costes como la atención médica a largo
plazo para excombatientes por lesiones producidas
en combate, gastos comprometidos para veteranos,
los costes de la deuda con la que se ha financiado
la guerra, la sustitución de equipos, etcétera,
etcétera.
En total, las estimaciones hablan de que tan
solo estas dos guerras terminarán costando
entre 4 y 6 billones de dólares.)
¡Menuda cantidad de dinero!
Para que nos podamos hacer una idea de su
dimensión real podemos decir que equivale
a todo el gasto militar de los países europeos
de la OTAN durante los próximos
15 y 23 años, que se dice pronto.
Vamos, que todas estas aventuras militares
son auténtica ruina.
Pero, ¿sabéis que?
Creo que es muy importante fijarse en la factura
para ser más prudente en el futuro.
(Por ejemplo, cuando una visita Estados Unidos
una cosa que llama la atención es el mal
estado en que están las infraestructuras:
carreteras, metros, ferrocarriles, etcétera,
etcetera.
De hecho el tema de las infraestructuras empieza
a ser un problema.
Pues bien, tan solo con lo que han costado
las guerras de Irak y Afganistán los Estados Unidos
podrían tener las mejores infraestructuras
del mundo.
Bien, hasta aquí creo que la cosa está clara,
hemos visto cuánto le cuestan a los estadounidenses
las aventuras militares de Washington por
el mundo.
Ahora, me parece interesante que echemos un
vistazo a cuánto gasta realmente cada año
en Defensa el Gobierno Federal.
Y ya os adelanto que puede que os llevéis
alguna sorpresa.
(EL VERDADERO GASTO MILITAR)
Más o menos creo que todos lo sabemos, el
presupuesto de defensa es con diferencia el
más grande del mundo.
Fijaos, para 2017, por ejemplo,
es de unos 560 mil millones de dólares a
lo que hay que sumar, como hemos visto hace
un momento, unos 60 mil millones más para
gastos de operaciones.
Esto viene a suponer aproximadamente 3 veces
el gasto militar de China o 9 veces el gasto
militar de Rusia.
Sin embargo, estas cantidades no recogen todos
los gastos que el mundo militar le genera
al gobierno de Estados Unidos.
Pensemos, por ejemplo, en el  coste de los tratamientos médicos de los heridos en combate,
o el gasto que suponen las partidas para veteranos.
Echad un vistazo a este gráfico:
Sí, como veis, si tenemos en cuenta todas
estas partidas, el gasto derivado de las Fuerzas
Armadas crece hasta más de 900.000 millones de dólares ¡al año!
¡900.000  mil millones de dólares!
Y aún nos quedaría aparte gastos de seguridad
nacional, como muchas partidas del gobierno
que financian a agencias de inteligencia,
como la CIA.
(Pero es que incluso si tomamos exclusivamente
el presupuesto del Departamento de Defensa
y las armas nucleares, es decir 620.000 millones
de dólares, vemos como el esfuerzo militar
en términos de PIB es uno de los mayores
del mundo.)
Miremos por donde lo miremos,
las cifras en juego son desorbitadas…
Sin embargo, antes dar la cuestión por finiquitada,
esperad un momento… porque el dominio militar
de Estados Unidos resulta algo menos impresionante
cuando tenemos en cuenta algunas factores:
Primero la diferencia de precios, es decir,
no se pueden comprar las mismas cosas con
un 1$ en EEUU que con un 1$ en China, por
ejemplo.
Si corregimos esta cuestión vemos como el gasto militar de Estados Unidos vendría
a equivaler a
la suma del gasto de China y de Rusia.
Sigue siendo mucho pero ya no es tan impresionante.
Y segundo, muy importante, cuando tenemos
en cuenta la evolución de los últimos años.
Me, explico, en dólares constantes, esto
es, corrigiendo los efectos de la inflación,
el gasto en defensa real ha caído desde 2010
un 25%
La reducción más grande en décadas.
Y en cierto modo esto es lo que preocupa a
muchos analistas y políticos de Washington,
especialmente del Partido Republicano.
¿Puede ser que a pesar de todo el dinero
que Estados Unidos gasta hoy en defensa no
sea suficiente?
Veámoslo.
(¿UN PODER MENGUANTE?)
Desde la caída de la Unión Soviética
y el consecuente final de la Guerra Fría, como
parece sensato el tamaño de las Fuerzas Armadas
de Estados Unidos se ha reducido sustancialmente.
Hablamos de menos submarinos, menos portaaviones,
menos bombarderos, menos soldados, etcétera, etcétera.
(A cambio también han llegado nuevos equipos
como los F22 “raptor”; los bombardero
B2, los recientes F35; una nueva clase de
portaaviones, nuevos cruceros,o, también,
entre otras cosas drones y misiles de alta
precisión.)
Sí, así es, y toda esta renovación tecnológica
tiene dos consecuencias: por un lado ha incrementado
las capacidades militares de Estados Unidos,
pero por otro lado también coste de los equipos
y las operaciones.
Y claro, el presupuesto como hemos visto lleva
años hacia abajo.
(“Años de subfinanciación nos han dado
una fuerza debilitada que, a pesar del arduo
trabajo de nuestras valientes tropas, está
mal equipada para manejar las misiones que
seguimos lanzando”.
Edwin J.Feulner,
fundador y Presidente de la Fundación
Heritage.)
Por todo esto en el Partido Republicano y
también, hay que decirlo,
en gran parte del Partido Demócrata
parecen tener las cosas claras: hay que incrementar
el presupuesto militar.
El excandidato a la presidencia y famoso Senador por Arizona,
John Mccain, que por cierto es el Presidente
del "Comité de Servicios Armados del Senado", es uno de los políticos que más  empeño tienen
en esta cuestión y ha propuesto incrementar
hasta los 800.000 millones de dólares.
Dicen que la actual financiación escasa ha
causado por ejemplo los accidentes que la
U.S. Navy, la marina, ha tenido en el Pacífico.
(“Relevan al comandante de la Séptima Flota
tras varios accidentes con buques de EEUU
en el Pacífico”.)
Y también que las nuevas amenazas, como Corea
del Norte o una China cada vez más fuerte,
algo que ya hemos visto en VisualPolitik,
obligan a renovar todo la infraestructura
estratégica.
(Y eso no es algo barato.
Tan solo rehacer y modernizar el arsenal nuclear,
esto es las armas nucleares; los bombarderos,
los misiles y los submarinos, como ha prometido
Trump supone una inversión en los próximos
30 años de más de 1,2 billones de dólares.)
Sin embargo, amigos, si gastas más que nadie,
mucho más, y aún así no llegas, ¿no será
que tienes que replantearte tu campo de acción?
¿No debería tal vez Estados Unidos modificar
de alguna manera su rol para no verse involucrado
en conflictos y crisis continuamente en cualquier
lugar del mundo?
¿Llevar el gasto militar mucho más allá
es una cuestión de Seguridad Nacional o de
interés de la gran industria armaméntisca
que de una u otra forma financia generosamente
lobbys y campañas políticas?
Estas son las pregunta.
Las respuesta quedan abierta.
Pero ahora, turno para tí.
¿Crees que EEUU debe incrementar su gasto
militar?
Déjanos tu respuesta en los comentarios y
también en esta encuesta.
No te olvides darle a like si te ha resultado
interesante el vídeo y por supuesto suscribete
a VisualPolitik si no lo has hecho.
Tenemos muchas sorpresas por delante.
Un saludo y hasta la próxima.